presidential hopeful is now
president-elect
Bola Ahmed tinubu the former Godfather
of Lagos has left the economic capital
for the political one
and the frenzy has followed him here
in the National Collection Center in
Abuja as president arrives
professionally confirming his win in the
presidential race
known as a political King maker and one
of the most influential people in the
country now with a massive task ahead
you'll have to address widespread
insecurity economic downturn and high
youth unemployment
let us create prosperity
and yeah
let us feed the people
changing the anger from our midst
he went on to call on his opponents to
join forces with him for the sake of
Nigeria I see president-elect while they
prepared to contest the election results
in the courts
the main opposition parties have said
that this election was rigged into
nabu's favor citing voter
disenfranchisement fraud and what they
call a biased electoral Commission we
spoke to the vice presidential candidate
of the labor party who came third place
but won both Lagos and Abuja are you
confident that the youth folk could have
actually changed the course of this
election it changed it changed the
course of the election but now been
denied
yes I'm confident about it it did happen
the labor party has said that they will
appeal the election results within the
stipulated 21 days
meanwhile tinubu is on his victory tour
let me see if I can get him
from here from here
once leaving the center heading over to
meet the incumbent president buhari
after receiving a certificate the
results are in the paperwork filed but
the election outcome is far from Final
Sky News Abuja